the criminality you have admitted may be
called an unrestrained campaign of rape
and abuse of women
it could be described as the work of a
serial rapist but it may not be possible
to encapsulate succinctly the broad
Devastation you have caused
through sexual violence and exploitation
all the time carrying the unique and
defining office of a police constable
various guidelines drafted by the
sentencing Council are relevant to
individual offenses and some of the
overarching guidelines also apply
including the domestic abuse guideline
but it is not necessary for me to set
out their contents in detail in these
sentencing remarks because the gravity
of all subsidiary offending can be
reflected fairly in the overall
sentences for rape
generally throughout there is high
culpability and greater harm
the guideline for rape provides that
sentences above 20 years imprisonment
are appropriate for a campaign of rape
submits that such sentences would be
appropriate in the individual cases of
at least five of your victims
the maximum sentence is life
imprisonment
apart from the guilty pleas there is no
material mitigation beyond your lack of
previous convictions
I have to bear in mind that the total
sentence must be just and proportionate
which means in this case that it is not
right to Simply add together all the
sentences likely to have been passed for
individual counts and impose a total
that would lead to a wholly
disproportionate outcome
the defense have not served or relied on
any psychiatric or psychological report
on you
in order that the court had an
independent professional assessment of
you I ordered a pre-sentence report
you described childhood trauma to the
probation officer which must have
affected your personality
you grew up with parents who drank to
excess and neglected you
when they separated you became the
target of abuse by a stepfather in your
teens
like any child you should have been
nurtured and taught moral strength and
you were not
as an adult you abused alcohol yourself
although you were able and careful not
to do so when working
this indicates that you were able to
control yourself when you chose to
there is no mental health issue beyond
the inevitable depressive impact of
custody
a less credible part of your account to
the probation officer is your claim that
you are unable to recall your acts of
sexual violence and degradation towards
women
I have to conclude that this is
minimization because you are yet unable
to face the enormity of the abhorrent
acts you did while a serving police
officer
the principal aggravating feature common
to all the offenses I'm dealing with is
your use and abuse of the role of a
police officer
all the victims were aware of your
occupation and effective diet some of
them you specifically reassured tricked
or intimidated abusing the trust that
the public vest in police officers
furthermore the sheer number of offenses
of rape is relevant to assessing overall
criminality and the domestic context in
some of the counts represents a
violation of the trust and security that
normally exists between people in an
intimate setting
other aggravating features of particular
offenses include repeated violent rapes
including when women are unwell
ejaculation false imprisonment to
facilitate the commission of sexual
offenses use of an imitation firearm a
police baton and a whip to assault and
threaten
and we're going to step away from some
of the more violent and gruesome details
from Mrs Justice Chima grubb's
sentencing of metropolitan police
officer former metropolitan police
officer David Carrick she talked there
in the sentencing about the malign
influence of men like him how she said
it stands in the way of improving
women's dignity using the line courage
calls to courage everywhere
which was the rallying Cry of the
suffragettes talking about the fact that
he prevented these women coming forward
because they did not believe think that
they did not think that they would be
believed because he was a police officer
on reduction in sentence for a guilty
plea applies in your case by section 73
of the sentencing code 2020.
the court must take into account the
stage at which you indicated your
intention to plead guilty and the
circumstances in which that indication
was given
a sliding scale is applied
you denied all the crimes you were
interviewed about until the admissions
by way of guilty pleas there was no
acknowledgment on your part that the
accusations made against you were true
and the police and complainants prepared
for a trial
this case has been opened by the
prosecution on a full fact basis
I would have allowed a reduction of 15
incentives to allow for your guilty
pleas to the majority of the charges
which were entered in December 2022 with
a trial date of the 6th of February 2023
having been fixed some months earlier
in respect of the earliest charges those
on the separate indictment on which you
were arraigned only in December 2022
you indicated swiftly that you did not
contest them except count seven which
has been left on file and you pleaded
guilty in January 2023 I would have
allowed one-third reduction
in reaching a conclusion on the correct
level of credit for your guilty pleas I
have recognized the impact of one
particular feature
between July 2022 and December 2022 you
were removed
and the judge now uh considering when
she makes her judgment on sentencing at
the point that David Carrick pleaded or
did not plead guilty she said that
initially he said that he denied any of
the offenses or that the woman had
consented for a year between December
2021 and December 2022 he said he
pleaded not guilty and it was only just
in the last couple of months in December
and January 22-23 that he did plead
guilty but he said she says you have not
expressed remorse or regret and in fact
unable to recall some of the offenses
she says you are unable to face the
enormity of what you did
or consensual
you are removed to rampton on the 22nd
of July for assessment and treatment
thereafter your lawyers had limited if
any contact with you
or news about you
it was only after the court intervened
seeking an update in your treatment that
on the 16th and 18th of November the
consultant psychiatrist responsible for
you at Brampton Hospital provided a
conclusion
this was that you were not suffering
from any mental disorder requiring
treatment in hospital and you would be
returned to Her Majesty's prison
belmarsh when Arrangements could be made
for you to be kept under 24-hour
surveillance to protect your life from
another attempt at your own hand
those representing you informed the
prosecution and caught swiftly after
your return to prison that you would be
pleading guilty
in the meantime as I have indicated the
victim t on the separate indictment had
come forward and so further offenses
were laid against you and as I've said
you changed your pleas to guilty in
January 2023
in all the circumstances I will allow 20
percent guilty plea reduction in the
notional determinant sentence that would
otherwise have been appropriate
I conclude from all the circumstances
and information before me that you were
driven to try to commit suicide as a
self-pitying reaction to the shame
wrought On You by these proceedings
rather than from remorse
the starting point it has agreed between
the parties is an assessment of
dangerousness
section 308 subsection 2 of the
sentencing code
introduced by the sentencing act 2020
provides that we're a court
has to assess whether there is a
significant risk to members of the
public
of serious harm occasioned by the
commission by the offender are further
specified offenses the court must take
into account all the information
available to it about the nature and
circumstances of the offense
may take into account all the
information that is available to it
about the nature and circumstances of
any other offense of which the offender
has been convicted
may take into account any information
before it about any pattern of behavior
of which any of the offenses above forms
apart
and may take into account any
information about the offender which is
before it
serious harm is defined by section 306
subsection 2 as death or serious
personal injury whether physical or
psychological
this predictive assessment must be made
as at the date of sentencing and on the
premise that the offender is not in
custody
the author of the pre-sentence report
concludes that you pose a high risk of
causing serious sexual and physical harm
to the public and presently to yourself
I'm sure the test is satisfied because
of the Persistence of your commission of
serious sexual offenses particularly
rapes against so many victims over such
a long period of time which has already
led to Serious harm
I'm sure that you present
a grave danger to women who might be
persuaded to be alone with you in
Intimate situations and this danger will
last indefinitely
I've considered guidance from Lord
Thomas the Chief Justice
in the crown and varinskas
I have to consider what former sentence
should follow this determination
section 285 of the sentencing code
applies to those offenses you committed
after the 4th of April 2005 which
comprise the majority
I consider that the seriousness of the
offenses which I have to sentence you is
such as to justify the imposition
uh as a last resort of a sentence of
imprisonment for life
indeed only such a sentence will meet
the gravity of the offending I have to
deal with you for in combination with
the rescue pose
similarly for the five offenses of rape
which fall out with the sentencing code
scheme I'm satisfied that life sentences
are required to meet the gravity of the
offending and the risk you will continue
to pose
I have assessed very carefully whether
given your abusive position this case
should attract a whole life order
the rare sentence of last Last Resort is
a life sentence with a whole life tariff
in the crown and the can synaga and Shah
2020 ewca
crim1676 the court of appeal Criminal
Division examined conjoined cases
involving serious sexual offending on a
scale of extreme gravity
although life sentences with minimum
terms to be served of 40 years were
appropriate after a trial none of those
cases reach the threshold for a whole
life tariff in the view of the Court
none of those offenders was a policeman
and the court did not have drawn to
their attention any potential scenario
close to the one presented to this court
however the prosecution specifically
does not seek to persuade me
that your offending fits the description
of quotes wholly exceptional
circumstances which the court indicated
would justify such an order
I've also scrutinized the Judgment of
the court in another recent conjoined
case the crown and Stuart cousins Tustin
and Hughes 2022 ewca creme 106.3
in which the offender cousins appealed
against the whole life order imposed on
him
following a notorious Abduction of a
young woman from the Streets of London
accomplished while he was an off-duty
police officer by use of his warrant
card followed by her rape and murder
the court accepted that police officers
are in a uniquely powerful position
in respect of the fixing of minimum
terms where a mandatory life sentence is
required by law are set out in schedule
21 of the sentencing code a different
scheme to the one I have to apply
Lord Burnett chief justice stated the
principle quote in our view the correct
approach is to focus on the facts which
in a rare case might lead to the
conclusion that a whole life order is
appropriate
close quote
at paragraph 83 having explained the
correct route to a whole life order in
that case he continued
quote this was as the judge said warped
selfish and brutal offending which was
both sexual and homicidal it was a case
with unique and extreme aggravating
features
Chief amongst these as the judge
correctly identified was the grotesque
misuse by cousins of his position as a
police officer with all that connected
to facilitate Miss everard's kidnap rape
and murder
we agree with the observations of the
judge about the unique position of the
police the critical importance of their
role and the critical trust the public
Repose in them
end of quote
had the court in McCann imagine the
facts of this case would they have
equated it to the gravity of the
near-miss mass murder attempt or the
foiled terrorist atrocity which the
court considered would compel
a court to attach a whole life Terror
tariff to a discretionary life sentence
the standout future is the element of
abuse of the status of a police
constable
but having considered the matter with
care I've come to the same conclusion as
the prosecution
of the utmost gravity though this is the
wholly exceptional circumstances test is
not met
thus the imposition of a discretionary
life sentence without a whole life
tariff must be accompanied by an
evaluation of the notional determinate
term that would have been required to
Mark the gravity of the total offending
had a life sentence not been imposed
that term provides the start of the
calculation required to reach a minimum
term an offender must serve it must be
for the shortest term that is
commensurate with the seriousness of the
offenses before the court
Mr Williamson King's Council in his
distinct and in his succinct and
well-focused mitigation submits that the
criminality before this court does not
reach the extreme limits found in the
cases of the offenders McCann and sinaga
I do not agree
your offending was over 17 years and
encompassed 12 victims moreover the
singular element which elevates your
offending as a brutal serial rapist into
that company is the principal
aggravating feature of the explicit or
implicit use of your occupation to
entice reassure or intimidate your
victims
you have to bear in mind that my
function is to impose appropriate
punishment and when that is served the
parole board will decide how to protect
the public thereafter
decades will have passed before that
time comes
I conclude that the notional determinate
sentence that would provide a just and
proportionate punishment is 60 years
to that guilty plea a discount of 20
will be applied
it is to your credit that you did not
contest a trial
your decision deserves this recognition
because there is no doubt that a court
hearing at which evidence is given and
challenged provides a particular ordeal
for victims
from the resulting term of 48 years I
have to set two-thirds minus the time
spent so far in custody which is 491
days
stand up David Carrick
[Music]
I've made ancillary orders for
deprivation pursuant to section 153 of
the sentencing Act 2020. and restraining
orders under sections 359 and 360 of the
ACT
they will remain in force until further
order
the victim's surcharge applies
I make no sexual harm prevention orders
given the nature of the sentence I'm
about to pass
on the main indictment on counts 1619 29
30 31 32 38 39 42 and 43 the sentence is
four years imprisonment on each
concurrent
on counts 24 and 25 the sentence is
seven years on each concurrent
on count six on the second indictment I
impose a concurrent determinate sentence
of nine years
31 sentences of life imprisonment are
imposed on the main indictment on counts
one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen fourteen fifteen Seventeen
eighteen twenty
22 23 26 27 28 33 34
40 and 41.
also five life sentences are imposed on
the second indictment on counts one two
three four and five
this makes a total of 36 life sentences
the minimum term you will have to serve
before the parole board can think of
releasing you is 30 years
239 days
and you may go down
[Music]
this little Mr Williamson the court
salutes the courage of all the victims
and their families and I hope they're
able to thrive in the rest of their
lives
the teams of police officers concerned
have worked hard to bring this case to
court and to keep the confidence of the
victims
to do so under the fierce scrutiny this
case is attracted is promising for the
future
the crown prosecution service lawyers
and Council have met tight deadlines set
by the court and put the case together
fairly and effectively
the defense team has met the challenge
of dealing with an evolving set of grave
allegations and a completely
disorientated client with patience and
professionalism
the court wishes to recognize that work
and to thank all of you
well Mrs Justice Chima grabbed there
handing down a sentence of 30 years
239 days before David Carrick can be
considered for parole
she looked at his position in society
she said that it was his role her role
to enforce punishment but it's up to the
parole board to decide when he will
actually be released 17 years of
offending 12 victims in total and the
expression implicit use of his
occupation and aggravating Factor when
she was considering that sentencing she
said that you present a great danger to
women and that that danger will remain
indefinitely but not given a whole life
order because she said that it was not
wholly exceptional circumstances it was
quite striking when we heard the number
of those offenses being read through
numbered one by one at the end gives you
some real grasp of the number of
offenses that this man carried out these
though a flavor of some of them but the
brutality uh that he brought to bear on
his victims and those victims being paid
tribute to at the end there by the
Justice saying that she salutes them and
their families and hopes that they are
now able to thrive
on our crime correspondent Martin brunt
is at Southwick Crown Court a
substantial sentence which we thought it
would be Martin given the severity of
what he did over so many years to so
many women
[Music]
yes I think perhaps not as high as some
people had anticipated I think some
people and including me thought he might
get something like 35 years but maybe 30
essentially doesn't make a great deal of
of difference at this stage
um she said at one point the judge that
she was giving in a 20 percent
um reduction for his guilty pleas
um although she talked about his shame
rather than his remorse she didn't pull
her punches she said that he'd had a
spectacular downfall for a man charged
with upholding the law and empowered to
do so even to the extent of being
authorized to carry carry a gun and that
really was one of the main themes of her
sentencing remarks that he had abused
his power as a police officer to entice
reassure or intimidate his victims and I
think that was always going to be the
case although
officers police officers are often given
compounded sentences where they commit
crimes on duty none of his crimes were
committed on duty but very clearly and
obviously to the judge he used his
status as a police officer to help him
commit those crimes and we heard from a
number of victims didn't we yesterday
who said that they were encouraged to
meet him because he was a police officer
telling some of them that they would be
safe with him because he was a police
officer and then threatening them within
one case a gun perhaps it was a replica
gun nobody can be sure but um showing
his warrant card to others and then to
many of his victims telling them that
because he was a police officer if they
ever did complain to the authorities
about his attacks on them their word
would not be believed over his
and Martin we're expecting to hear from
the police and also the crown
prosecution service
foreign
yes we're going to hear I think
immediately here from the officers who
investigated finally investigated uh
Carrick now these are officers from the
Hertfordshire police force who worked
also with beverlyshire and
Cambridgeshire police forces and those
three were involved because the victims
largely came from that part of the world
but um we're probably going to hear from
the senior officer involved in the
investigation I don't know that we're
going to hear from the Metropolitan
Police at this stage they weren't
involved directly in the investigation
and we did hear from them from them
yesterday
another in a long line of apologies from
the Metropolitan Police for allowing
Carrick to to continue in his job even
when they did know that he had at least
been accused of predatory behavior over
many years so yes we'll hear from the
detective involved in this prosecution
of Carrick and we'll also hear from the
crown prosecution service which of
course played a big part in the
formulating of the charges to which
Carrick eventually was persuaded to
plead guilty persuaded by the the wealth
of evidence against him the numbers of
victims who had complained about him and
a very obvious pattern of behavior over
many years in which ultimately he was
convinced that he couldn't argue as he
had originally on his arrest that he
either couldn't remember those crimes
all those attacks or
um he had only ever had sex with any of
those women by their consent
and Martin
there was clear I I felt sort of
simmering anger but behind what a lot of
what the judge was saying where she
talked about why some of the women had
not come forward how they felt that they
wouldn't be believed she said it spoke
to the moral Corruption of the way that
victims are treated in society and and
the fact that that he had used his
position was clearly an aggravating
Factor here
yeah she talked about um his malign
influence um I didn't quite catch
everything she said but she talked about
how that stood in the way of the
revolution of women's dignity so
I'm sure we would have heard something
similar uh from a male judge but perhaps
there's an added poignancy that um we
were hearing those words from a woman
judge I mean she was very um very calm
and collected in her delivery as you
would expect from a judge but yes I
think perhaps we could we could read
behind that that she did have an awful
lot of sympathy and empathy with with
those women
um victims from whom she had heard if
not directly and she'd heard their
Victim Impact statements yesterday when
they went into
Dreadful detail about how they had lived
in fear they had suffered great physical
pain
but also they've been intimidated by
Carrick into not reporting what he had
done to them and then subsequently had
gone on to suffer in their own
relationships uh their lives their
mental health had been damaged and
particularly one victim I spoke to
yesterday a fellow police officer at
David Carrick who said that she had
lived ever since
2004 after he raped her with her guilt
for not reporting him at the time but
said look you know maybe I had a greater
responsibility report to report him I
was a police officer but I'm also a
human being
and Martin we can hear like loud voices
behind you there are a lot of people who
are very angry about this case aren't
there and a lot of people down there
protesting against violence against
women
yes this is a protest group that was
here yesterday uh been here today since
um since about nine o'clock since since
before the um the hearing started
essentially making their voices uh heard
about the issue the whole issue of male
violence and holding this case up as a
shining example of how men do go
undetected uh in when they are
committing crimes against women I mean
of course many are are caught and
convicted but they're holding up the
case of David Carrick as somebody who
was allowed to commit many offenses many
terrible crimes against women even
though some of those offenses were
reported there was a gathering of
intelligence around this man who
was a police officer as well a man as
the judge said empowered to hold up the
law in spite of all that he was allowed
to continue for more than 20 years
serving as a police officer
and Martin this has led to a spotlight
on the Police Service on the
Metropolitan Police especially and
reforms within it
yes I mean it's early days isn't it but
there really is a determination to
change things I have to say it's not the
first time we've heard this and
certainly after the abduction rape and
murder of Sarah everard by a serving
metropolitan police officer much the
same concern was expressed by the
Metropolitan Police
and it's perhaps sometimes difficult to
see what exactly has changed although of
course carrick's offensive go back many
years to 2002
[Music]
to the first year that he'd served as a
metropolitan police officer but the
commissioner the newish commissioner Sir
Mark Rowley of of the Metropolitan
Police has countless times
since he got the job in September said
that he is absolutely determined in the
wake of the Carrick case and others of
appalling bad behavior by officers to
root out bad cops to encourage other
officers
to inform on their colleagues who are
exhibiting bad behavior bad language
committing crimes
and and also examining the disciplinary
process which he says stops him sacking
bad officers but it's gone beyond the
Met
uh in the last few months again in the
wake of the carrot case because
he was allowed to become a police
officer even though there were
unconvicted allegations or unpersued
allegations against him he was still
given the job he was then vetted again
some years later
and and although by then there was a
mounting catalog of allegations against
him he was still permitted to keep his
job so the whole question of vetting is
one of the very big issues that not just
the met but police forces throughout
England and Wales all 43 forces are
trying to get to grips with and going
through
police databases to see if any of their
offices over the years have been accused
but not pursued over largely predatory
behavior or misogynist
misogynistic activity and there may well
be a number of officers who will find
themselves being investigated again
perhaps prosecuted perhaps thrown out of
their jobs it really does seem as though
there is certainly a collective
determination within policing
to get to grips with um with these
problems but cynics will say we've heard
it before let's see what happens in the
future
and indeed Mark Rowley said himself
didn't he that we could see a number of
people appearing in court every week in
the future about this
[Music]
yeah he said that um because of the
efforts he's being he's making uh to
root out bad behavior he should he said
we should expect two or three of his
police officers to be appearing each
week in court over uh coming weeks
um but even he doesn't know the extent
of the bad behavior corruption criminal
activity that he might uncover given
that he's going at it hammer and tongs
it may be that there are even more than
he anticipates but he he's made it clear
a number of times that there are several
hundred officers within the ranks of the
Metropolitan Police that he would gladly
get rid of if he could
and Martin just returning to the victims
in this case the women that this man so
brutally hurt over the years I mean is
there is there a prospect has there been
any word that more may come forward
yes uh I interviewed um the
investigating officer from Hertfordshire
police Hertfordshire because
um Carrick lived in stevenage and some
of his victims do did
um he said that yes
after their appeals
that followed
carrick's guilty please when the whole
Carrick story emerged they made appeals
for more victims to come forward and yes
some have they are being interviewed
their complaints their allegations are
being investigated he wouldn't go into
how many perhaps he might be prepared to
say more today let's let's wait and see
but certainly there are more potential
victims making allegations against
Carrick and I think it's almost
inevitable that there will be more
charges
and if you're just joining us on Sky
just a reminder that we're bringing you
the news that the former metropolitan
police officer David Carrick is going to
serve at least 30 years behind bars for
attacking a dozen women over a 17-year
period a two-day sentencing at Southern
Crown Court has heard how he used his
power and control to carry out a catalog
of violent and brutal sex attacks we're
just staying with Martin brunt our crime
correspondent because we're expecting to
hear from the police and and the CPS do
they have questions to answer here
Martin
sorry I missed that that you I think you
said the police have questions to answer
um yes I think um one of the
difficulties I think in getting answers
to those questions today is that um the
whole Carrick case is now going to be
part of an independent
um inquiry that's been going on into
the murder of Sarah everard by Wayne
cousins serving metropolitan police
officer as he was at the time
um the Carrick case is being added to
that
inquiry and it well it may be that those
that we want to talk in detail about
what went wrong in the carrot case
um they may decide that that's going to
be examined very obviously and very
publicly
and they may be reluctant I think to go
into the kind of details
about the problems that um that weren't
overcome in in the Carrick investigation
certainly when I spoke to the senior
investigating officer last week he was
very reluctant to go into the mistakes
that were made over many years so the
allegations that were made and
investigated by not just the
Metropolitan Police but by heart for
chair police and Hampshire police and I
think Sussex police that heard some of
those allegations they weren't pursued
for a number of reasons in the past the
investigators in this case have said
that there was a particular case where
a woman claimed that Carrie could raped
her and then withdrew
her complaints and made the point that
it's very difficult in those
circumstances to pursue an allegation
where it's simply a case of the word of
the victim against the word
of the suspects but you know perhaps
there should be ways of exploring the
pursuit of such crimes
um without
um the backing of the victim but I do
understand that um that that does
present evidential uh problems and I'm
sure the prosecutors will tell us as
they often do that you know you do have
to reach a threshold of evidence that
will convince a jury
without the evidence of a woman who says
she was raped then that does present a
problem
thank you Martin we're just getting word
from the Metropolitan Police of a
serving police officer who's just been
charged with rape PC Jordan Brown
attached to the central East command
unit charged by postal requisition on
Friday the 6th of January with rape and
three counts of actual bodily harm
alleged to have occurred off duty
reported to police back in 2019 and an
investigation was launched he is now
though suspended from Duty does this
perhaps suggest to you Martin one of
these cases that we have been talking
about cases that are being re-examined
by the police
foreign
yes I don't know whether that particular
case brings from the recent
start of the re-examination I think this
is probably
an investigation that's both been going
on for some time if they've already got
to the point to the stage of charging
that officer I imagine it goes back
further than the initiative that's been
started by
commissioner Sir Mark Sir Mark Rowley I
mean unless I know more about the case I
can't really tell you but I think it's
an example of what we're going to hear
much more of in the coming weeks and
months as
the Metropolitan Police but other forces
to turn over that stone that was one of
Mark rowley's phrases
um you don't know what you're going to
find but you are going to find
evidence of some crimes that will
inevitably lead to charges and court
cases and lots of more bad publicity for
the Metropolitan Police but in launching
his initiative
the commissioner is in a very conscious
that you know he is going to unearth and
prompt an awful lot more of bad
publicity
against his Force but it's something
that he's prepared to put up with and he
says it's necessary to go through what
did he say um there's going to be an
awful lot more pain
and if you're just joining us just
remind her that former metropolitan
police officer David Carrick has been
sentenced to at least 30 years behind
bars for attacking a dozen women over a
17-year period 30 years and
239 days 17 years of offending and 12
victims uh really horrific attacks on
these victims a crime correspondent
Martin brunt is outside the court Martin
there was quite a lot about
psychological reports here and a
revelation in the sentencing that he has
tried to take his own life but the judge
saying that she believes she tried to do
this because of Shame rather than
remorse that will have affected the
sentence in won't it
yes I mean I didn't I didn't catch
everything that she said but she she
talked about how
um his defense have not argued
um that there have been any personality
disorders or certainly no psychiatric
mental health issues
um she made the point that he had been
um sent to rampton the secure hospital
for assessment he was seen by a
consultant psychiatrist maybe more but
the deduction of that psychiatrist was
that he wasn't suffering
from any mental disorder she did refer
to at least one suicide attempt but she
did very forcefully make the point that
and she said you were driven to try to
commit suicide from shame rather than
any sense of remorse we did hear
Yesterday from
carrick's defense Barrister who did say
that Carrick had exhibited remorse the
judge was conscious of that and
and I think perhaps made some allowances
for that although she did go on to say
that he had for a very long time
uh denied that he committed any crimes
said at one point that he couldn't
remember them
or that where he had had sex with his
victims he'd have been
um with their consent
um so she was quite damning on what she
thought of what he had said for such a
long time he did eventually plead guilty
but it took many many months after being
charged she gave him some reduction in
his sentence and she talked about 20
percent reduction for his guilty pleas
so he could have been looking at um a
rather much longer sentence than the
minimum 30 years that she's given him
just over 30 years but of course that's
the minimum sentence he'll have to serve
at which point if he wants to apply for
parole he'll be able to do so but of
course like all prisoners
serving a life sentence he will have to
convince a parole board that he's safe
to be released into the public the
parole board would have to decide if he
presents at least a minimum or at most a
minimum risk before he can be freed
hey um Master brunt I'll Grant customer
down there outside the Crown Court thank
you very much for the time being let's
just bring you uh another piece of
breaking news in the last few minutes of
on secretary James cleverley has been
making a statement in the House of
Commons about the Turkish earthquake he
has revealed to the house that three
British Nationals are missing we know
that the death toll is feared to be in
the many many thousands there and many
many more injured but the James cleverly
stating that three British Nationals are
among those who are known to be missing
so far
there's a breaking news about another
story that came out during the David
Carrick sentencing Surrey police say
that an incident at Epsom College in the
early hours of Sunday morning they've
made a statement about this this of
course the discovery of head teacher
Emma Patterson who was found dead
alongside her husband George and their
seven-year-old daughter it is now being
treated as a homicide investigation a
murder investigation Elena veslenovich
is in The Newsroom for us what can you
tell us Melina that's right sorry police
just confirming that it is now being
treated as a murder investigation they
say that they were caught the ambulance
service was called a 10 past one and the
police found three bodies which they're
confident are those of Emma Patterson
her seven-year-old daughter Letty and
George Patterson on side there was also
a firearm that was recovered however the
police say they have to wait for the
completion of the post-mortems later on
this week before they can become
confident to say what the cause of the
death was however that firearm they now
say was registered to George Patterson
the police also say that they had been
in contact with him just days before
this incident on the 2nd of February
about this firearm however that was
purely routine and they are confident
that no one else is involved in this
tragic incident for now okay Milena
thank you very much a pretty Grim
morning for news isn't it the breaking
news this hour that David Carrick
sentenced to 30 years 239 days in prison
for a catalog of abuse over a long
period of years and over a large number
of women also bringing you the latest at
one o'clock on the earthquake in Turkey
in Syria three British Nationals now
confirmed to be missing there stay with
Sky News
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
you're watching Sky News at one coming
up this afternoon breaking news former
police officer David Carrick is
sentenced to 30 years in prison after
admitting a catalog of violent sexual
crimes including rape the minimum term
you will have to serve before the parole
board can think of releasing you is 30
years
239 days
and you may go down
we will have the latest live from
southwark Crown Court
also coming up live for you from luffa
in Turkey this afternoon
remarkable pictures emerge of a small
child being rescued against the odds
from underneath the rubble
in Syria a young boy is saved after
being dug out of the wreckage of a
collapsed building by the white helmets
here in Turkey an anxious way for many
people as they try to find out what's
happened to their loved ones
with helmets
painstaking work in freezing conditions
this is a scene in gazian Step as teams
pick through Tangles of metal and
concrete from thousands of flattened
buildings
hello good afternoon
the former metropolitan police officer
David Carrick has been jailed for life
with a minimum term of 30 years for
dozens of sex offenses Cara could
admitted 49 sex offenses including
dozens of rapes against 12 victims
carried out over a 17-year period the
sentencing judge Mrs Justice Chima Grubb
said it was a spectacular downfall for a
man charged with upholding the law
five life sentences are imposed on the
second indictment on counts one two
three four and five
this makes a total of 36 life sentences
the minimum term you will have to serve
before the parole board can think of
releasing you is 30 years
239 days
and you may go down
well our crime correspondent Martin
brunt is at Southwick Crown Court and
Martin this is a substantial sentence
isn't it
it is not unexpected because he is one
of the most prolific sex offenders we've
ever seen in court in in the UK
the judge early on in her sentencing
remarks ruled out the possibility of
jailing him for the rest of his life but
as as his own Barrister pointed out
yesterday the long sentence that he
expected might effectively mean that he
will never be released and even though
he has been given the chance of asking
for parole it would still be up to the
parole board to determine whether he was
safe to be released and that might not
be an easy hurdle for him to overcome
the judge said that he had taken
monstrous advantage of women behind an
appearance of propriety and
trustworthiness and she talked about his
campaign of of crimes as bold and
Relentless trusting that no victim would
overcome her shame and fear to report
him and that was very much the theme of
the judge's remarks
the aggravating Factor one of a number
of aggravating factors but the
overarching aggravating Factor was
that if not directly he had indirectly
used his status as a police officer to
instill fear and intimidate his victims
broadly by telling them that if they
were to report his attacks on them they
wouldn't be believed because he was a
police officer and his word would count
for much more than theirs now
a lot of his of his victims uh fell for
that they believed that and that
explained why they didn't report him but
there was an extraordinary
um statement from one of his victims
yesterday in court who said that she
and perhaps she suffered some of the
worst of his behavior she'd been taken
back to his apartment as it was then he
put a gun to her head he raped her he
then put his hands around her throat
he raped her a number of times after
that left her bruised and bleeding with
bite marks on her and then she said she
went to an a e department at South
London Hospital
and when she told a nurse that she'd
been raped by a police officer
the nurse told her to be careful imply
that she should be careful about
reporting what had happened and who had
raped her suggesting to her according to
the victim that she was young and she
should probably get on with her life and
forget about it because an allegation
against a police officer was unlikely to
go to court
Martin thank you very much and we are
expecting uh to get a statement from the
police involved in this case and the
grand prosecution surface also in a
short time outside uh Southern
magistrates court and we will return to
it when we do
um Jane you join us at I think what
might be the worst possible news from
the scene here in Eartha where we have
been uh all day uh the
workers here have been doing everything
they possibly can to try to find 35
people who were trapped underneath the
wreckage of this seven-story building
when it collapsed in the early hours of
yesterday morning after the 7.8
magnitude earthquake devastated this
building all the buildings around it are
deemed unsafe to living but it was this
one that completely collapsed pancaking
down and trapping those 35 people
beneath it amongst them two children
throughout the morning the diggers have
been gingerly scraping away at the
detritus and careful not really to
disturb the pile too much anxious that
one wrong move could see the building
collapse still further rescue workers if
you were with us earlier you'll know
they occasionally paused to listen to
call out a maybe to hear a cry for help
nothing and then they continued
residents who lived in the building have
been stood around the area throughout
the day hoping against hope that their
loved ones would be brought out of from
beneath this Rubble we've just seen two
blankets taken to cover that area there
was a lot of excitement to start with
that is now ebbed away and there is a
serious concern that those that are
going to be brought out of this pile of
rubble sadly will have breathed their
last while trapped under the rubble we
believe it's two together we know that
there's a some parents who have been
hoping that their children would be
brought out alive they have been taken
away within the last half an hour or so
um
fearing the worst I'm sure but
there are still 30 odd people still
underneath this rubble and
who knows you know it may be it may be
good news but given that there are
blankets hiding the entrance and exit of
that uh
Gap that's been dug really over the last
I don't know hour or so
um I I fear it is not good news it's uh
the first earthquake uh here yesterday
morning about four o'clock in the
morning I had a magnitude of uh 7.8 it
struck at 17 minutes across the floor
that was Turkish time about 20 miles
from the city of gaziantep close to
turkey's border with Syria
in the direct aftermath there were
dozens of aftershocks and then nine
hours later 24 minutes past one in the
afternoon a second huge Quake measuring
7.5 was recorded at pazuchuk in the
province of Cameroon
uh the the worst affected areas were
along the east antilian fault line
within the last hour the foreign
secretary has been making a statement in
the Commons James cleverly said there
were concerns for three British
Nationals in the region
as of this morning we know that three
British Nationals are missing and the
foreign office is crisis response Hub is
working to support the at least 35
British Nationals who have been directly
affected by these earthquakes we assess
that the likelihood of large-scale
British casualties remains low we will
continue to stand by the people of
turkey and Syria we will deliver a to
those in need wherever they are and we
will do so and as we do so
we will work with our allies and
partners around the world to ensure the
most effective humanitarian response
I was these workers covered in the white
dust from the rubble it's absolutely
freezing and the locals have been
building fires actually on on the
Pavements here Jane to try to protect
themselves and their neighbors from the
bitterly cold whether they don't want to
leave while there is still hope that
those trapped beneath this wreckage
could still be found alive let's get the
very latest from uh Tom Clark a warning
that some viewers may find images in his
report distressing
you know
thank God you're safe a rescuer in
Northern Syria says to a little girl
trapped in broken concrete too terrified
to speak
soon after she's freed a moment of
Triumph one that's being repeated across
this demolished landscape
that this is a disaster so vast in scale
and temperatures so cold that moments
like this will become less frequent as
time passes
concern is high for Syria where Rescuers
must do their best in towns scarred by a
decade of War already crumbling and
poorly resourced
officials estimate more than 1500 have
died so far
in Turkey the number of casualties is
rising too
the Turkish vice president confirming
nearly 3 500 citizens had died and more
than 20 000 are injured 8 000 had been
rescued from Rubble he said a nearly 6
000 buildings had collapsed
the extent of Destruction caused by
Monday's earthquakes is still unclear
the World Health Organization estimates
23 million people including 1.4 million
children are likely affected and the
death toll could reach 20 000.
we all stand with you in this moment of
unspeakable grief
this is a moment
when we must come together in solidarity
as one Humanity
many buildings clearly survive the two
enormous earthquakes and hundreds of
aftershocks but thousands of older or
poorly constructed buildings collapsed
others pulverized
some casualties have been taken on
military planes for treatment in
Istanbul as they come in hundreds of
volunteers wait to go out
offers of help are coming from around
the world here Pat